[Music]
me being from Staten Island I know what
it's like to grow up in the outer
boroughs of New York City in the pride
of Jamaica Queens South Jamaica Queens
in New York City the author of darkness
to light two-time NBA champion writing
his memoir darkness to light Lamar Odom
good to see you here sir
you look good thank you you are welcome
and do you get that a lot
I do yeah yeah that's a good thing I
guess from being all that I've been
through why did you write this um
therapy no kidding yeah it was a great
therapy session while I was a good
therapy for you oh just because of some
things that I revealed I don't think
I'll have all agree from ready to the
loss of my son and the loss of my mother
and my grandmother and I think that
helped help me get over it just sitting
down and telling your story and putting
it out there and in the addiction part
ain't know which part hopefully it can
help some people what are you hoping to
help people with Lamar um that they can
overcome addiction as a book about
triumph grief darkness to light
Lamar Odom here on the Rich Eisen show
Oh what do you think of when you see
this though this book of your your face
on the cover you're looking sorry this
is really all hard to believe it's hard
to believe that it's all that has helped
so many people are so fast the reaction
that I get from people is great and
hopefully continue I think it's number
one in Barnes and Nobles if I'm not
mistaken look that up Chris let's get
let's get out of this man all those
accolades out there everything happens
for a reason
everything happens you you that is you
believe in that philosophy that's true
darkness to light are something that my
grandmother used to say to me what was
done in their darkness comes out in the
light and what would lead her to say
something like that just wise woman so
what what do you want to make sure that
people know about you Lamar Odom that
they may already assume that you they
know about you I mean
reading this book cover-to-cover what do
you want people to know about you you
think that they they don't already Oh
have a cod heart and I'm giving loyal
and loving father how many kids do you
have - two and when you started playing
basketball is that something that you
think made your life better or oh
definitely made it better especially uh
you know when my mother passed away like
remember just going to the park and just
playing all night I think that was like
the first time I was like a loud stay
out all night he said yeah just in the
neighborhood yeah just creep out
whooping all night okay it's the only
thing that really like took my mind off
at basketball was my celebration at that
point well I mean and then the way you
got into college basketball wasn't easy
either I mean it was it was not an easy
path for you you didn't just like get
taken somewhere and that's where you
played and then follow me nothing's been
tall and easy
maybe um except from except for playing
basketball was like a gift from God
mm-hmm I knew I was gonna be an NBA at
the age of 10 years old 10 yeah how told
you when you returned 510 so you were
dominating at that point in time I mean
for a ten-year-old I was always playing
with older guys though when you say
you're playing with older guys you're
talking about on the playground is what
you're saying
yeah okay I'll playing the league's you
know like the league's were like 16 and
under so anybody that we might know that
you were playing with against at that
point I mean I was playing with Ron
Artest and Ellen Brown played a you
right same way a you teen idiot how
about Alton now Oh incredible running
the Sixers incredible I'm extremely
proud of did you know at the time and
you think
Alton had some executive was always
really book smart you always really
understood the game well he went to Duke
right yeah so um no one should be
surprised
Lamar Odom here on the Rich Eisen show
best player you ever played with was
Kobe Bryant he's a yab that was a quick
quick yeah
a trick question not you did not stutter
but I know what what did he do over you
Lamar do you think oh man no well the
the year that I won on 6-minute a year
they shoulda really just gave him that
award because all of his arm his
greatness just rubbed off on me
he taught me how to be the selfish and a
healthy way to healthy selfish and that
yeah I was on shoe and the reality show
with my ex-wife like the number one
reality show and I won six manatee yeah
I don't think that I would be done again
that was really selfish but it was
selfish for a good reason
so during your sixth man year you were
you were doing the reality show with
Chloe or with wizard with the whole
Kardashian would glow he was shooting to
spin off for the Kardashian show how are
you able to pull something like that off
it's tough concentration but I owe that
all to him practicing with him every day
and he was teaching me when he didn't
even know he was teaching he was was he
cool with the fact that you know doing a
reality show is well no I never asked
him that but I mean I got permission for
the Lakers to being a locker okay and so
off you went
during that thing well I mean so Kobe
was the best player that you ever you
ever played with easily
well hands-down now you know I'm I'm
reason why I'm asking is because I just
want to understand how you know you
integrated here into the Los Angeles
community after the Clippers you came
back with the Lakers and how difficult
that might have been how to out what if
what was Phil's role and all that do you
think Oh amazing teacher and I think um
at that point in my career probably was
a perfect for me to be taught about Pat
Riley and then Phil Jackson like the yin
and yang as far as coaching styles
myself I learned a lot from fool do you
got a good Pat Riley story for me oh I
think that um the one Pat Riley story I
remember was when he told us that he was
retire I get gave like this incredible
like football coach speech hey oh how we
should just all be better but he just
pulled you home in the locker room yeah
and there was emotional some guys like
broke down and we're like almost in
tears but he said it was best for the
team that's what was his message again
what was his message to you guys just to
go out and be the best that we can be
mourning off the court and Lamar Odom
here on the Rich Eisen show what was the
boys the lowest point for you at Lamar
even my teacher yeah oh man just in life
I would say losing my son
I said losing my son and I thought it
would be no no light to enter that
tunnel and no light at the end of the
tunnel yeah and how do you deal with
that grief how does somebody you deal
with her grief like that I don't know I
think I'm still dealing with that every
day
all right you know I just had basketball
basketball kind of just woke me up I had
a reason to live I think that's why I'll
get back to basketball this summer
playing the pic you're playing in the
big three yeah I know we had cube here
the other day yeah did every fun did he
reach out to you yeah that'd be fun just
the camaraderie days it's great and
didn't have no opportunity to play for a
black owner on sports black owner in
sports is big cube yeah the only black
owner I think in sports
well he's Michael right yeah Michael
Jordan do you ever consider playing for
him did I ever happen no no the
difference is Michael John owns a team
um coupons only sure yeah yeah he does
yeah I'd see you on every team in the
league did you ever think of making a
comeback in the NBA in recent oh I have
I have but I think that time has passed
me by but I would love maybe to play in
the Philippines or play overseas why is
that to my career so your give me
playing with a big three get your game
going yeah and then
maybe playing the Philippines why send
up a little bit I mean Philippines is
great they love the Lakers and
basketball is the first love do okay you
have any thoughts on what's going on
with the Lakers right now Lamar Odom oh
I mean it's too bad but I think they'll
get it together so they got the King
everything to go right for him so how
often do you speak to the Bron do you
speak to him often yeah often at all but
you still believe in what he can do oh
and credit was the best okay all right
so when people pick up this book you
want them to learn what about themselves
Lamar what do you think that they can
overcome anything anything if you put
golf and family first mm-hmm Lamar Odom
a memoir darkness to light a true real
Lamar Odom on Twitter and on Instagram
thanks for coming in thank you but I
really appreciate it good luck to you in
this book and I hope you sell a ton of
them thanks a lot you got it that's
Lamar Odom right here on the Rich Eisen
show we are back Eric Stonestreet still
making his way to the studio here
talking about secret life of pets Kansas
City Chiefs and so much more don't go
anywhere for more of the Rich Eisen show
tune - audience Channel 239 under red TV
for free on BR live or download the Rich
Eisen show app